ladies and gentlemen welcome to the uh
tim dillon show from austin texas ray
kump
um has come down with kovid and uh
which i knew was gonna happen i should
not have even had him
uh come here i should have canceled my
uh christmas festivities but i did not
i brought him
and lucy uh his girlfriend who you know
from his podcast
and this was like the first time they
had left their house in a very long time
they contracted coveted immediately the
symptoms are mild
um they're at the four seasons right now
um on
my credit card ordering room service
curing themselves of covet they're
having a hot chocolate service the last
time uh i stopped by the room they're
having a hot chocolate and churros and
marshmallows and
and then i'm moving him into my back
house until he tests negative and he can
fly
he sent me a list of foods
that he wanted for groceries and they
were lentil soup
mac and cheese now imagine you have
coven
and you're sending someone to the store
you would think you might get water or
orange juice pedialyte
please stop that's your you're done now
for your contribution every time i look
at you doesn't mean i want you to talk
thank you
uh but you would think you you would get
water vitamin d vitamin c whatever
uh nobody gets pedialyte by the way who
gets pedialyte
people that want to be rehydrated from a
covenant i've never heard anyone get
pedialyte that's like something drunks
take
when they're [__] up all night
right
i don't know if if you're really
dehydrated i've heard that's like the
the trick it's for like people that are
on molly all night i think the next day
if they're like drunk
i haven't heard of like pedialyte for
covin but
um
[Music]
listen to this list of groceries lentil
soup which is probably an accident mac
and cheese
peanut butter and jelly
country white type bread
penne pasta
jar sauce
eggs
canned coffee like starbucks or
something similar
so that's how they're gonna get over the
covet is with the macaroni and cheese
and peanut butter and jelly
and penne pasta i gotta go out to the
grocery store and get this for them
and i will put it in a in the cupboards
and in the uh refrigerator so they can
go and uh destroy my home
but this is when you invite people to
your
uh place of residence for a holiday
and they get sick with kova this is what
happens
colin powell said to george w bush about
iraq if you break it you own it
i broke it now i own it
i own them now
they are my responsibility until they
test negative which is happening to a
lot of different people
people come to your house you think
they're going to be there you know 12
hours
all of a sudden they test
positive now you gotta figure something
out
gotta put them in a room or an attic or
a basement
gotta put them in a panic room
gotta lock em outside in a kennel
until they test negative
which could be 7 8 9 10 god help us 15
day i mean
you'd really hope
that they test negative
sooner rather than later but until that
i have uh they'll be eating macaroni and
cheese
that is a list of food if you if you
didn't want to heal from covid if you
wanted to just
get coven you would eat that food
that would be the food that you would
eat uh macaroni cheese peanut butter and
jelly penne pasta jar sauce
i like that he specified jar sauce
because otherwise i would have been
cooking i go oh
i'll make a sauce for them
hopefully they're doing well
they have very mild symptoms they
probably got the omicron which is a head
gold
they're vaccinated
but you know now it's uh it's i got uh i
got it everybody uh it's uh around me
he's getting sick
it's the final wave of uh the covet here
you know god willing
and uh
everybody's got it
ben's wife thought she had it but she
might not have
everybody uh has this or everybody's at
least panicked with the idea that they
they may have it now
the real interesting people are the
people that have not gotten it yet
the people that are two years into the
pandemic and have not gotten it yet
they're either immune
or
for whatever i mean
those people are walking around
completely panicked
that at any moment
their time is going to be up
i don't know how
you haven't gotten it up until now but
ben was one of those people
um
that didn't get it and he just got it
this is the wave where people that
haven't gotten it are going to get it
this is the highly
transmissible one so even if you're like
ben and you do so little
and you're usually on a golf course or
you do very little
even someone like him who barely works
can get it
you gotta imagine if he can get it if
ben can get it
anyone can get it
if ben can get it a toothless hermit
who lives in a ramshackle old cabin by
the lake can get it because they do the
same amount
so if ben is unsafe from this
that means anyone can get i mean any
human being engaged in any level of
effort any level of work can pick this
up
walk across the street by mistake
you can get it
so
now of course it was mild uh for most
people it was not mild for you it was
you got really sick
you were very sick right yes i was yeah
and how long were you and you're uh
you're not fat no and i take my vitamins
and you take your vitamins but it can
still make you sick yes
and you you were at home uh being sick
while i was on the road
earning why i may have had delta you may
have had the other variant that's right
perhaps we don't know or you had the
omicron and you were just kind of
playing it up that's possible yeah you
were maybe playing it up a little bit i
wasn't but it's a possibility i could be
like i've been playing it up i think
because ray kump who's 800 pounds
is doing relatively fine he can type out
get me mac and cheese
but you
who are svelte and in good shape were
like moaning and crying and like rolling
all around on the floor
don't you aren't you slightly ashamed of
that
raymond is soldering through
being the fattest person either one of
us have ever met in real life
and you
a
relatively in great shape person
completely fell apart are you not a
little ashamed at that
yeah it's messed with my head a little
bit it is isn't it yeah
odd
but this is what happens
this is what happens uh i think
sometimes when
we allow
ourselves
to
not
uh
think of our mission
and our purpose
right
and instead of thinking of our mission
and our purpose
this program
uh all the things we try to accomplish
and do
you decide to go and get sick
during the final days of the tour a tour
that you had complained about
and you had been very upset about
because it was very hard for you
to like take planes
you would talk about how hard it is to
get on the plane
and then would they did they ask you to
fly any of the planes no right it was
just primarily
well you would sit on the plane and you
didn't like it it was very hard for you
all the adoring fans and the people that
would come to you and say hello it's
very hard for you so it was odd that in
the last few days of the tour
you just crapped out
i'm raising my hand yeah may i suggest
something no you're you're you're you're
free to speak
perhaps now i'm judging this because rey
has covered right and tested positive
that is true like me and when you tested
positive you tested a very faint line
she said i i was sitting there in the
kitchen no no i was sitting there in the
kitchen
and joe rogan's witch doctor q a nurse
came over
and you tested a very faint line
that was almost on the edge of you not
having it yes that is correct okay so
now go on with what you're gonna see
okay so i wasn't feeling that bad at the
moment i didn't get any sleep but i was
sweating but i was like i'm pretty sure
i have covered right right so now
raymond is over here day two day three
he's fine but what what happened with me
is i got the regeneron immediately and
then i started feeling bad so maybe the
regeneron is what made me sick
perhaps or
do you want to hear my theory okay do
you want to hear my theory sure
i believe
you had been complaining to your wife
no i truly believe this i believe you
have been complaining okay to your wife
that you had to work
because
we know that you're the bane of your
okay why are you raising your hand again
i have not even advanced my theory okay
yeah no because they no i i'm i'm dead
serious there's something's up
something's up and we need to figure out
what it is because this seems
now you almost did it again where you
said your wife was sick and then but
then you finally came back
but like you did it you were trying to
do it again wouldn't stay in abilene
texas i don't know but you you were
cooking something up again
you were and everyone knows it and the
fans will know it
they'll hear it in your voice what were
you saying okay stop raising your hand
you freak
what were you saying now
what i'm saying will you be can i can i
ask for your honesty yes can i ask for
your honesty for the love of god can you
please
just be honest for christ and not
continue to obfuscate
continue to lie
continue to
um
you know basically
completely
and utterly disrespect
myself in this program
and the fans
but what were you gonna say well if i
had a positive test why would i play up
being really sick while you're gone
because all i need would be a positive
test that's my ace in the hole and then
i wouldn't have to go on the last three
dates
your test was barely
positive
truly
i don't know what you cooked up with
that witch before i got there
your test was barely
positive
and then you decided
to have a throw a pity party for
yourself for an entire week
where you threw a big pity party
and then you got your wife in on it
and when you went to the the in-laws
for fried biscuits or whatever they were
gonna serve you
you then tried to pitch her that she
should take the fall
for a week
so you two didn't have to come back and
you didn't have to do any work
now i know that you're that this is some
kind of ridiculous statement but
it's very odd that ray kump
okay ray cump who weighs as much as a
chevy tahoe
it truly not a suburban but at least a
tall
more than a traverse
he
more than an equidox
yes he is doing uh doing this doing well
and ben avery
a lanky
person
was unable to handle this i'm just
throwing it out there hey i don't know
what's going on
i don't know what's going on i'm just
i'm just saying that we see you
and what you believe and who you are
better help online counseling is very
important that everybody get their
mental health straight
especially now we've lived through this
crazy time everyone's lost it
you gotta find it better help is great
what else ben
is there something interfering with your
happiness yes you
or preventing you from achieving your
goals you and your wife
well betterhelp will assess your needs
will they kill you and your wife no no
no no what will they do they'll just
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
and you can start communicating just in
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online i love
it there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas everything's
online get it happening make it happen
well the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your account and if you don't like your
counselor you can switch and get another
one
it's not a big deal i also like the
immediacy of it because sometimes you
don't feel like going to therapy even
though you have a scheduled appointment
that's right and this way if you feel
bad just shoot them a message it's so
essential
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today to together we can visit
betterhelp.com
tim d tim d that's better help and join
the over one million people have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so many more are coming
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
timberland show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com tim
d that's right
visit betterhelp.com
tim d
adam mckay's new movie don't look up
getting panned why don't people like it
it's about climate change
adam mckay the brilliant comedic
director of things like step brothers
and anchorman
no longer wants to make stand-up comedy
he said making movies about white guys
in suits doesn't feel right because
those white guys in suits have ruined
the world
so he doesn't want to laugh at that
anymore this is uh from adam mckay i'm
paraphrasing but that's pretty much what
he said
so now he wants to make
films about important uh impactful
issues like climate change
the problem is a lot of people
don't think it's good no i don't know
how many people
you know i just know that he's got
leonardo dicaprio in it right
uh you also have jonah hill he's got
jonah hill meryl streep
he's got a great cast
the problem is they say it's a little
heavy-handed i guess in the uh
the messaging yes i haven't got to see
it yet but it seems to be getting paid
not that good yeah well nothing's gonna
be good when it's um
about
an ideology rather than a story
uh if it's a movie i mean ideologies
aren't necessarily designed to be movies
so
even if they're correct even if they're
the right one
um it's it's probably not going to be
that good
vice was not good he's actually not good
at this
he's good at making those movies about
silly white guys in suits because he is
a silly white guy in a suit what he's
not is this like
you know um he's not francis ford
coppola he's not and i don't care i mean
i i i don't care he's never gonna do
anything with me anyway but he you know
he made the big short that was fun but
that was the edge of what he could do
like that was as serious
as he could do it and he had margot
robbie in a tub explaining like credit
default swaps like it wasn't that
serious
but he's a genius and what he's done
with comedy is amazing he's left his
stamp him and will farrell on comedy
um
but this stuff
that he's doing now that he wants to do
because he wants the emmys he wants the
awards the articles
it's not going to be good
and a lot of people uh you know have
been kind of saying that have the
critics
yeah i got roger ebert's website right
here what did he say what did roger
ebert say well he since passed away but
i believe nick allen is like running it
now he's like oh good i forgot that
roger ebert died they're carrying on the
spear he died of covid last week with
you
is that what happened to roger ebert he
got covered at the end of the tour
and he had to lay in a bathtub for seven
days
it's almost irrelevant that this is
mckay's worst film yet because there's
something far more maddening about the
promise of the potential and the
importance that don't look up voice upon
itself this is of course about global
warming and how we're not doing enough
about it a funny premise for a
star-studded comedy with disturbing
stakes but mckay has filled this parable
with hot air wanting us to marvel at and
then choke on its mediocre jokes
so nick allen's sort of ripping at the
shreds there from what i've heard it's
just not funny which which you don't
wanna that's the last thing you want
when making a comedy it's someone to say
it's it's not a cop well i don't think
he wants to be funny
oh interesting i mean this is the point
is that he doesn't want to be funny
comedy is no longer about being funny
it's about having people go yeah
you're right about that so i don't think
adam mckay is disturbed by that i mean
maybe he is
but
i mean this is a dude who said i don't
want to make any comedies anymore
i want to make the type of comedy
that
uh
people in in in my circle will like
my circle of polite multi-millionaires
who will then say
oh that's so important
such an important issue
thank you
and you know that seems to be what he
wants to do so he's accomplished that he
did it
it's not for you anymore dummy
they hate you
they don't want you to laugh at what
they do
they don't think you're a human being
they don't value you
they don't think you should own a car
they don't think you should be able to
drive anywhere they don't believe you
should choose your job they don't
believe you should have free speech they
don't believe you should be allowed to
go on the internet and say what you want
to say they barely believe you should be
able to vote
um yeah and they don't care that you
like their movie
on top of that
and
icing on the cake they don't care if you
think they're funny anymore
does not matter to them
that ship has sailed
you were lucky
they don't want you to have custody of
your own children
they don't give a [__] if you like
they're moving
truly seth rogen doesn't care if you
like
uh
what did they just make
abortion mrs claus
whatever it is
what is it called santa inc santa inc
right about sarah silverman
blackface sarah
who was very funny at one point
uh but is now spends all her time on a
podcast
apologizing to random people because she
said the n word in 2004
why don't you go why don't you go help
someone that needs help instead of
sitting on your podcast and apologizing
this is self-serving [__] here
so everyone that i grew up liking has
become cringe and it's it's really truly
disgusting
and the answer is not to make like you
know ben shapiro charlie kirk
uh fantasies about you know uh female uh
snipers killing school shooters no that
movie's good tim you don't really get
yeah [__] you
maybe it is good i don't care that's not
the answer either
the answer isn't to get a bunch of
conservative psychopaths together to
make uh
right-wing movies either okay
but yeah they don't give a [__] if you
like their movie that shouldn't shock
you
nobody cares it's not about like
it's not about like being uh funny it's
about
or
it's about
pissing
people off
and making other people happy
which is
should be the essence of comedy but when
it's when it's
strictly
about
politics all the [__] time
and
there's no other
element that anybody thinks about when
they make something
everything will suck
things will be bad
comedy is the gray area
comedy should live
in the area that is not explicitly
defined
by who somebody voted for
there are deeper things about the human
experience that we can convey
besides
who somebody voted for
it's silly now
and um
[Music]
yeah but you know
good luck
good luck everyone i i hope that you
enjoy it and maybe it is good
maybe i'll love it maybe i love it
what if i like it
and i tell everyone to [__] off
i want to talk about this story a
bodybuilder killed his parents in long
island
in a 3 million home
i love where i grew up so much
and i have so much pride in it
and that's why
i get upset with ben when he lies about
covid because i've taken him to the
greatest place he'll ever be long island
new york and i've allowed him to meet
these people
i've acted as a tour guide and showed
him
the promised land a uh bodybuilder in
new york
killed
his parents he shot them
on christmas morning
it's a long island christmas story
a bodybuilder
who had a little roid rage
shot
both of his parents in the face
on christmas morning do you have the
story ben yes his name is dino his name
was dino
tell the people about dino and his final
act he didn't kill himself he's still
around i believe yeah he was arrested so
this is a 29 year old bodybuilder from
brooklyn according to cops in a report
pumped up dino thomasetti dino
is accused of shooting his 65 year old
father in the back and 64 year old
mother in the head dino
at their tony hewlett harbor home just
after 10 a.m
merry christmas dino
hewlett harbor's a nice area of uh long
island
i like that area three million dollar
house
3.2 3.2
and so now daddy got it in the back
and he shot mommy in the head mm-hmm
that's right
so then what's that song uh santa got
run over by a reindeer or grandma got
run over by is that it yeah
yes that's the song grandma got run over
by a reindeer it's like how does it go
i'll play it for you right now play it
dino baby
uh so there's a lot of iterations let me
uh i think this is a good one
[Music]
shot his mommy in the head
then he shot papa in the back
they were having fun at hewlett harbor
where everyone is jewish no one's black
that's just demographics
dino said i'm upset
and he shot his parents right in the
hand
merry christmas
it's fun
and you saw a trail of blood
and on those heated kitchen floors you
saw a trail of blood
all right
i feel bad
do we know why he did this
uh so let's see
there's one thing i've learned
about family
is that it can be trying
i mean really
i'm never advocating killing your
parents
here's what i'm saying
family in general especially during the
holidays ben
can be trying yes
right yes
now is it so trying that you would shoot
your mother in the head on christmas
morning
you'd hope not
right
sure but i don't know
so where did did he flee after this yes
he fled
i'm trying to figure out uh it it
doesn't seem that we have a motive come
to austin texas dino
come right down here to austin texas we
got your back
supposedly dino and the mother were best
friends is what i'm reading
it's it's everybody is shocked by this
news the mother owned a dance studio
stars on broadway and linbrook
a woman outside of dino's building in
east williamsburg who identified herself
as his best friend told the post that
he's definitely not a violent person i
mean he looks very violent
in long island when people say they're
not a violent person it means they're
incredibly violent
i know people that's been said about
and that usually means uh they're uh
incredibly violent
he's not a violent person you know he's
getting fights here and there
occasionally he's been arrested a few
times you know battery small time b and
e he broke into his ex-girlfriend's
apartment once smashed your head through
the wall but you know he's not a violent
guy
you know we came home a few times he had
a gang war in the street
just a bunch of people beating each
other with chains and bats
but he's not really a violent guy
i feel bad i don't want to make fun of
this horror well i have some good news
the parents are alive they're in
critical wait a minute hold on hey
i smell a hallmark christmas movie
i smell a miracle
ben i can't believe you buried the lead
because i here
i thought the story was gonna be sad
i thought it was going to be
irredeemably tragic but now
benjamin avery our honest producer
is telling us
that the parents are not dead they're
not dead they're uh the father is in the
most serious uh condition right now but
neither a parent has died as of the
current moment
mom was shot in the head
and dad in the back dad was shot in the
back in the back
but nobody's dead
right no and the police have not
released a motive for the shootings
nor have they updated the public yet on
the condition of the victims so there's
a chance
that next year next christmas
they're all sitting at a table
eating
dinner
with dino
mom and dad
in the house
after he's gotten psychiatric help
right yes
but i think they'll still put him in
jail for this
even if the parents don't press charges
so here's here's something interesting
tim this is a interesting uh little side
note i don't want to chase rabbits with
the story but it says what
you don't want to what chase rabbits
you mean go down a rabbit hole well yeah
i mean i'm kind of making a matrix ref
reference i guess we just saw matrix
matrix reference yeah
why because i don't i don't want to like
veer off into the
into the uh the weeds here i'm trying to
stay on the story why would you say
chase rabbits is that not an expression
to you it's a rabbit hole you go down a
rabbit hole okay that's fair you sound
crazy
i was just listening to the matrix
soundtrack on the way here i don't know
why you made me see that the other night
it's [__] horrible
so it says here
a 2006 new york times profile detailed
how dino senior was once indicted for
allegedly illegally paying off union
brass throughout the span of a decade
federal prosecutors had also linked him
to organize crime figures
now is this significant
it could be
or is this everybody in long island they
they have links to that is also true
here are the three things about the
story
everybody on long island's a criminal
everybody on long island
has paid off somebody
and everybody on long island's kid wants
to shoot him in the head
do you see yeah so we've got three
definites
everybody's corrupt and everybody has a
kid listen i i love my family
all of my friends love their family
i i can count
on
my two hands
the times i've seriously thought about
murdering both of my parents
like started to make a plan
now most people i know have felt the
same way
i don't mean it's a passing thought i
mean considering
killing both of them
and fleeing and actually planning it out
in my head i've done that about seven or
eight times
most people i know
on long island have done exactly that
where they've planned out how they would
kill their parents and they would get
away with it
now maybe that's something people where
you grew up don't do
but it's kind of a rite of passage it's
sort of coming of age
if you can't fantasize
about beating your parents bloody with a
bat i used to fantasize about beating my
parents bloody with a metal bat
to the point where there was so much
blood going down their faces you
couldn't even see
who was who
they were so bloody
and i always thought about it around the
holidays i don't know why
maybe it's because it was easier to get
both of them in the same place my point
is this it's not rare to want to shoot
your mother in the face
on christmas morning where i come from
it is not rare to want to shoot pop pop
in the back
where i come from
maybe other parts of the country they
don't feel like that but in long island
if you want to be a man
eventually you got to shoot your father
in the back
now
some people don't do it
of course
they don't have the money
they're not confident
maybe they never grow up
but i'll tell you one thing about dino
junior
the bodybuilder
he's no joke
you know
now
here's the thing about long island
the parents on either side of that house
they're going to be well behaved
if this was as shocking as people say it
was
that means that there's other families
in that area
that are like [__] it could happen to
anybody
could get it
at any time
now this woman ran a dance school i do
not want to be
i'm not even trying to make light of
this it is my shitty job
occasionally i may say some things that
are uh but it is a story that i'm
fascinated by
because i wish to god i pray i truly
wish
i had i i
had the strength to kill my parents
but i didn't
because i'm weak
i'll admit that to the people listening
i'm weak i never killed them
they slept in separate bedrooms i'd have
to cap one and cap the other it was a
whole thing
do they do a
a if she survives and we hope she does
does the dance school
do a number
two for her to celebrate her
life
what's it called in limb brook stars lin
brook stars with a z yeah yeah well
there are no stars
in linbrook but
perhaps
they will do the right thing which is
honor this woman's legacy
with
a dance
number
and the number
will be
to honor
her life
you know which we hope she still has
and just saying i hope that happens
sooner rather than later
the dad and the grandfather have a
pretty uh sketchy record here what do
you mean
well the dad and the grandfather am i
gonna get shot for talking about this
why don't you protect me
we can always edit it out later but
since the dad and grandfather were
arrested for operating an illegal waste
site next to their company's brooklyn
headquarters in 97 and that year that
company pleaded guilty to filing fake
documents related to a project at
elmhurst hospital center in queens
uh said they had a 2.5 million contract
to build concrete decking for a new wing
at the hospital and had secretly and
illegally subcontracted the work to a
second company for 1.4 million enabling
them to collect a 1 million profit the
times reported the scheme came to light
after they failed to pay the second
company wow yeah they're criminals
in the same article the outlet reported
that the company was indicted for
racketeering in 1987 for bribing local
officials to let them illegally dump
construction waste in jersey
they eventually got off when they paid a
25 000 fine nobody deserves to get shot
in the face on christmas
i don't care what they did
you tell me their own son whacked them
how do we know that little dino did it
uh the police arrested him because he
was he was fleeing the scene but i you
make a good point here we don't have any
video maybe he was going to work out
did they ever think about that
no i'm dead serious
maybe little dino
was stressed out
and he wanted to go work out
well we have his instagram here right so
here's do we let's get into his head a
little bit let's get into his head okay
so of course hey
i'm i'm dino
you're in my [__] head now
[__] traffic
so it's a photo
here's we submit this to the court here
this is the picture of him sitting in
the car kind of looking ahead with his
watch
yeah and the caption says
don't bleed on someone who didn't cut
you and then he has the prayer hands and
then the 100
and then he says dinner to the aftermath
much appreciated much respect hashtag
thank you hashtag new york city new york
stay focused hashtag fitness
fashion
blessed
grateful i don't think he did it
i don't think he did it
i want to come out and support him right
now i don't believe he did it
he's being framed i'm dead serious
i i think he's being framed
by a gang land uh connection okay i
believe he's being framed
hashtag blessed
i don't think he did it
i don't think he's did it i think he's
too much of a [__]
i think he's too much of a [__] to
shoot his mother in the head
i know a lot of people
who said they were going to kill their
parents on long island and none of them
did you know why
because we live
because we have the worst generation
ever
of people
that got participation trophies
we got soft snowflakes
none of them
raised a hand to their parents
what we wish we wish uh dino the best i
don't think he did it and i will support
him
and i will the full power of the show
will be uh to support him well his
instagram still up i just texted you a
link if you want to
follow him or support him or anything
like that
let's see are there any comments on the
post i can't believe the police haven't
taken this down yet in long island they
should have taken no no leave it up
iron bros
oh somebody wrote bubba's gonna love
those muscles at rikers island
those killer shoes are just good comedy
two hours ago
16 minutes ago must be the steroids
insta blue check ghost do you have me to
get your blue jack
somebody goes are you the one who tried
to kill your parents i guess those
steroids got to your head
somebody writes bro
i know a good criminal defense lawyer dm
me
that's the best
that's my favorite one so far
long island's all about getting the hook
up you know
yo bro
i know a good lawyer
dm me
bro
listen dude
don't [__] worry about nothing
you shot your dad in the back
and you shot your mom in the head on
christmas day
you need a lawyer bro
you need a good lawyer
yo i know a good lawyer and then he'll
talk about it like he'll go out
you know for dinner and he'll be like yo
my boy
dude he got in some shed
he shot his mother in the head
and his father in the back
christmas morning
dude he only did 20 years
because i got him that good lawyer
dude 20 years for that
that's not bad
it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate but this is you know
it's a it's an unfortunate uh
cycle of violence
magic spoon cereal is one of my
favorites you know why because it's
there's no sugar it's beautiful they use
high
quality sweeteners like monk fruit and
xevia magic spoon is amazing you can
custom design
your own pack of different flavors
magic spoon is keto friendly gluten free
it's got like no sugar it's high in
protein
it's a really great cereal especially if
you like
sugar cereals the type uh that you ate
when you were a child
magic spoon allows you to feel a bit
naughty
but actually you're being nice
right
that's right right
we have been so successful
with magic spoon as a company because
people
like their product and they order it
over and over again
i love magic spoon i love the fruity
flavor because it tastes exactly like
froot loops but you don't have to feel
guilty do you feel guilty no that's
right why
because there's zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs carbs in each serving
that's 140 calories that doesn't i don't
feel guilty at all
about that it's soy free low carb gluten
free keto friendly
and do we have any type of deal for the
because it's not enough that it's just a
great product we got to sweeten the deal
without using sugar that's right so you
just how do we sweeten the deal
without using sugar by using a high
quality extract like monk fruit just go
into the description of this episode i
have the link right there it's
magicspoon.com
tim dillon to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try it today and be sure to
use the promo code tim dillon at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order
all right so tell them the deal
so remember get your next delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tim dillon and use the code tim dillon
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
thank you and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
this winter upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke posts and their new
seasonal lineup of how
well they have a new seasonal lineup of
bespoke post is this box of awesome oh
it's boxing awesome every time i do this
ad i'm very happy to do it because i'll
tell you right now
i love giving people gifts
i love it and i like giving them gifts
to keep on giving
and if you go to box of awesome
the bespoke post what you're able to do
is send somebody a monthly box
or you could get it for yourself
and what it does is it you can curate it
and tailor it to the things they're
interested in
and every single month they get this
surprise
that's amazing and and what does it have
and it has everything it could be tools
for camping well what's fun is it's
seasonal right isn't that fun so you can
get this winter you get some winter
cocktails cozy threads camping gear it
has collections for every part of your
life yes they sent me a knife this month
which was really really it was really
nice yeah i was actually i was shocked
how cool the knife was that's really
cool yeah i have it in a little sheath
what did they send dino tomasetti
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com because it's his quiz
it's a simple quiz that's right and then
that'll let you know what's gonna happen
mm-hmm what you get
well they won't tell you it's still a
surprise right cause your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
they'd know you
uh they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time oh that's
excellent
each box costs only 45 dollars but has
over 70 worth of gear inside plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business ninety percent of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up and coming
brand get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code tim
dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code tim dillon for 20 off
your first box
i'm excited
right
yeah
i got the gut hook knife
i'll give you a gut hook
i got some hot sauce too good for you
what did you write on your quiz you're a
cajun trash bag
did you get anything in the mail tim i'm
giving nothing ever
you've hijacked every sponsor that we
have you have it so that you and your
wife get everything and i get nothing
didn't you get us some pancake mix once
i was given that
did you like it yes it was very nice
okay good
so you'll be using box of awesome war in
the future for sure
50 000 cases at covet new york in one
day
retail sales up most they've been in 20
years
you as consumers were in the mood to
spend this holiday season
with retail sales soaring 8.5
over last year
online sales were up 11
and in-store sales up 8.1
between november 1st and christmas eve
the increase which was the strongest in
17 years does not reflect automobile
sales
customers splurged throughout the season
the boom saw apparel and department
stores experiencing strong growth as
shoppers sought
to put their best dressed foot forward
americans flocked to clothing
which experienced a 47 percent increase
in sales year to year as well as jewelry
a 32 percent
increase
the period included several weeks before
the omnicron covet 19 variant spread
widely in the united states
department sales uh department store
sales were up 21
while electronic products experienced
16.2 percent
growth
wow so it is a stronger holiday season
than i thought
it's a pretty damn strong holiday season
people are back out they're on they're
back in the saddle
they're buying
jewelry for the people that aren't dead
people some people aren't dead and they
should get a watch
they're buying clothes
they're stepping out
i miss the feeling of going to a long
island mall
during the holidays with my friends
and you would buy gifts for your
grandmother
or somebody there was something really
nice
about that you know
looking at the christmas tree lights
you know i mean
you don't really have that because you
didn't come from an area where people
really put up christmas lights not
really no no no
i came from an area where people did
they put up christmas lights and they
shot their mother in the head
and i i would never trade where i grew
up but i'm happy that
i'm like really really happy
that
um
[Music]
things are looking better economically
for people
people were like [__] it we're gonna
spend money this year we're gonna get a
couple of gifts i don't think i got
anyone gifts this year
i got you a little something a bonus but
a little charity stuff i don't think i
got anyone a gift
this year
i don't believe
i won
i didn't get anyone anything
i remember one of my tweets once was
another year of not didn't get or
receive any presents
i won
isn't that winning
but i'm happy that people are out there
spending that money
this economy might just you know peter
schiff keeps going it's gonna
die
but maybe not
maybe we just soldier on march on
we might be okay
it all may be okay
it may not
but
it could
i'm excited about the prospects of uh
strong numbers
from the uh
holiday rush
did you get anyone anything
i got you some gifts i got yeah
family members gifts what did you get
some charities what do you think for
people
uh for who like who for anyone well like
my wife likes the aviator nation stuff
so i got her some hoodies from there
nice i got my brother a check he doesn't
really like things and you know
oh that's oh that's nice uh
i gave cole some stuff i gave him some
bird dog stuff who's a sponsor of ours
oh good
uh that's really i mean a ton a ton and
tons of stuff
i got you a spider book
yeah i appreciate that to identify
spiders i appreciate it mm-hmm
now you and your wife are
you're stunningly generous people i
donated to charity how much
you want me to actually tell you yeah i
believe it was twelve hundred dollars
which charity uh this church that katie
knows for kids who don't have toys on
christmas yeah like i think we did four
families that's 300
well i think i think that was four homes
from what i understand i think four
homes yeah so it's 300 for each kid in
each home what do they get with that i
mean you can get you can get some nice
stuff you get a nintendo switch it's my
postmates
741 thank you so much
tell the other guy that he's awesome
sorry
to put the other guy back on
thank you very much i i appreciate
everything sir have a good holiday
okay thank you sir thank you
here you see what i just did
that's better than money
that's reaffirming someone's human
dignity
do you understand
the difference between me and you
that you just write a check
and i
actually tell people
thank you
that's the difference
if you had to
say what the difference was
that's the difference
um
i sent michelle 500 over zell
because she was doing
something like that
for the kids
i don't know if she was able to get the
money
so i believe i'll have to cancel it
but
you know
i just it's a lie that you're that the
kids get 300 dollars
i don't i know it's real it's a real
thing i don't think it's call my wife
because what
you give them twelve hundred dollars
and then the organization goes
and they buy two presents for each kid
they buy a water gun and something else
straight up
the presence costs eight dollars each
okay that's 16 per household they take
the rest of that money
okay
and they [__] pad their own pockets
truly
which is why i do direct
charity like what i just did on the
phone
i don't know why it's funny it's
literally affirming someone's human
dignity
okay
i'm donating ten thousand dollars
to dino tomaselli
i'm paying for his lawyer you know why
because i believe everyone in america
especially people from long island to
serve
they deserve
an adequate
defense did you meet any of the kids
that you supposedly gave gifts to no
interesting
i don't even know their names you don't
know their names no and you don't know
anything about this
you just wrote a check yeah
my wife told me that we should do it
so i did it well michelle texted me
and she said she was doing something
similar and i i sent her 500 on zell
and she couldn't get it so i had to
cancel the payment
but it doesn't matter
do you understand yeah because you still
did it i did it yeah but i will get my
money back
i've been trying to do charity for 10
years
can you get the
chicken nuggets yeah
i feel bad i feel bad i don't i don't
even like to it's bad karma to make fun
of you know dead people and [__] but
they're not dead
so everything will be fine as long as
everybody remembers that the holidays
are about love
and that
from very hard situations
we can find the love this kind of
reminds you of like jerry springer
remember jerry springer would do like
the the thought of the day and it would
have nothing to do with the show
the show be like lesbian
of midgets like fighting each other
and then jerry springer would be like
sometimes we're tested
and in those moments it's like jerry
what the [__]
are you talking about people are mad at
uh
paul thomas anderson's new movie
what is it about grooming age gap what's
happening yeah i saw the infamous
charlotte climber is mad about it on
twitter and some other but other people
are mad about it yeah some other people
are mad about it but i mean it's like
what is it again so he's 15. so uh
phillip super hoffman's son is 15 in it
and the lead singer of haim is 25 in the
movie and
it's a love interest so the age gap is
25 and 15. and you can see where people
have problems from there yeah but are
they [__]
i do not believe they have sex in the
film no
it's just like it's a cute little
it's a cute little you know high schooly
romantic thing well is it cute if
someone's 25 and someone's 15.
i mean that's cute well i think the
argument is that if it's a girl's the
older person and then the guy is the
younger person no i understand that but
if i made a movie where i was dating a
15 year old when i was 25 would that be
cute
it could maybe be done in a q a i don't
think so
it is a little we got to stop doing that
can we agree to that yeah
we got to stop doing that
it's not
college and senior year of high school
do you understand
25 and 15.
hey we got to stop doing that right
am i wrong why are you giggling i'm not
going to argue against this i think we
gotta we gotta slow it down a little bit
with that
i i'm saying truly
i truly believe it might be time in
light of
what we know about the world and the
amount of
children that are abused with impunity
like maybe it's time to just like
stop romanticizing that kind of chasm
when somebody's 15 when somebody's 18 or
19 they could do whatever they want they
could bang a 75 year old inherit their
[__]
house and they should
but when somebody's a 15 year old and
they're a child i don't know
yeah so this is
what
i think
paul thomas anderson's thing is he's
trying to make it hunky dory
in the movie from what i've read because
i haven't seen the film yet but it's
supposed to be a hunky-dory cute thing
meaning what meaning you know those kind
of relationships you've seen where like
the little boy is into like the
babysitter or whatever and it's kind of
cute it's like oh it's kind of i
understand that
i understand that
but
it's not a little boy that's a it's a a
child who's going through puberty or has
gone through puberty
and then the girl's 25 yes
but is there are they having are they
hooking up
i don't believe they hook up but let me
let me figure out exactly yeah but i
mean it's not
i'm not saying it's a big deal i'm not
saying that like
i'm not saying that this is uh you know
should only be released on the dark web
i'm just saying that you you can't you
know enough with that
that's why i didn't do call me by your
name call me by your name was originally
i was cast in it
i was one of the leads and call me by
your name
i was playing
the 17 year old elio
and they gave it to timothy chalamet but
originally they it was slotted for
timothy dillon
and
army hammer's role was going to be
played by wendy williams
and imagine how much better that movie
was going to be
have you figured out yeah yeah so i know
in the trailer she shows him his tits
but uh upon googling this it seems
tick-tock is
having a frenzy with this film uh says
tick talkers are accusing licorice pizza
of pedophilia
and uh this writer says that they
everyone needs to calm down about it but
tick-tock is just going absolutely nuts
they are they're very upset about this
because alana is 25 gary's 15. people
are viewing that the relationship
dynamic as is predatory and abusive well
somebody's 25 cannot show
their genitals to a 15 year old they're
they're tits
well that's their boobs i mean you
shouldn't do that
i know that this is the whole argument
like well if the kid [__] his teacher
he's cool
right but it does [__] up men
maybe not as much as women who are taken
advantage of you know
well what about this what if he's it's
being true to the era because it's it's
set in the 1970s is that fair
if i make a movie okay
about a slave
having a relationship with a white woman
okay okay
and her teaching him how to read
and then and i and it's true to the era
would i be
surprised if it was
poorly received
but do you see what i mean
how that might be a problem
or maybe people will be upset about that
and i go what was true to the era
you know
it was true to the era perhaps
you know what i mean
i'm i'm not saying you should ever
not tell a story
or
you know i'm i'm i started this talking
about
the mckay film saying
which i've not seen full disclosure
but
you know there's a lot of strong
feelings about it i don't think you
should ever like
not tell a story because it's not
politically correct
but
i think at the same time you might want
to you know balance
that
by not ever giving
anyone who's 25
the idea
that it's ever like okay
to like flash a 15 year old
uh pta has a rebuttal here okay and the
new york times so those
if he was ballsy his robot will be them
kids is tasty
okay so he says
in regards to the age gap pizza i love
when
make the ice cream different colors
yeah that's fun
the food dye the do your job and read
the quote
so in regards to the age gap it says
there's no line that's crossed and
there's nothing but the right intentions
it would surprise me if there was some
kind of kerfuffle about it because
there's not that much there
that's not the story that we made in any
kind of way there isn't a provocative
bone in this film's body
he might be right
right
yeah i guess so
uh tick tock seems to be going like kind
of the pizzagaty way with it with the
whole thing what are they saying well i
think they're just i i haven't got on
tick tock about this but usually what it
evolves into is like them zooming in on
a frame
showing like an ambler logo is rambo
giving it to him
hey ma'am
regardless i don't know if the film's
that good anyway and i mean his last
three haven't been that good so why
don't you make a [__] movie it's hard
i'd like to yeah i bet you would about
what going and lying
to ben avery li liathon
i can barely afford a [__] condo
because i pay you very well you and your
wife way too much money
way too much this is the narrative now
that you pay my wife too
i pay
way too much money
and i can't afford a condo
in miami
it's like hard
it's like difficult to afford a condo
because i've supported you and your wife
and your family
your entire family
and now i have to pay for the legal
defense of dino thomaselli
who's innocent until proven guilty may i
remind everybody thomas eddie thomas
eddie who gives a [__]
just like paul thomas anderson innocent
until proven guilty
is he up being held right now on bell
yeah he's being held
and uh he they won't really know what to
do with him until you know he will you
want my spoon give me your spoon yeah
there you go there you go they won't
really really know what to do with them
until the condition of the parents is
known
and as you know since you were on a you
were in a jury that that that's
important in terms of the uh
the sentencing here
so dino it's it's kind of a day by day
thing here
i'm guessing the trenbolone got him
though all the chinese steroids just
made him go insane he's five foot nine
235 pounds
man he looks insane
you blame it on the tremolo
that's what you're doing
i'd blame it on like the chinese
chemicals he's putting in his veins yeah
it's always someone else right china
tremblone
it's never that he made a choice to
choose mother in the head
what a rough way matt christmas
i wonder what sparked it
you think they had an argument christmas
morning
like on the phone and then he drove all
the way from williamsburg well
you know like what do you think it was
that that preceded him
um
trying to murder his parents
probably has something to do with an
inheritance right because you look at
the age of the parents they're 64 and i
think
65 respectively they're not why would it
be an inheritance i mean no one's dying
well if they're they're letting him know
that they're not going to either give
him the dance studio
or the the waste management uh thing
that the criminal dad's doing
maybe he's getting cut out
you watch too many movies
this is why i'm the helm of the show
because you watch too many films
and you don't really know
how real life works and operates because
you were raised in a chicken coop
you know what i mean and everybody you
know like you know is like a goat herder
so i'm gonna have to like remind you of
how actual the world's the world works
okay
that's probably not what happened it was
probably a very
like spur of the moment thing
he probably had a gun in his car they
probably got into an argument
i don't know what it was about
but it was probably very hot-headed
hot-tempered quick
i don't think he was going over to
demand that he was be given the dance
studio
you know
but i don't know what the [__] happened
but
i don't think it's all about trenbolone
you think it is well these people they
they like kill their families they burn
their houses down no i understand that
but i'm saying that like
it could have been that he probably had
roid rage
but i also think the parents were not
blameless
that's what i'm saying
the parents were not blameless
rarely are long island parents
completely innocent
you know
we know they're criminals
they might have been getting on them
maybe paul thomas anderson should make a
film about this
stop making these hunky-dory cute
films about the 70s
and the suburbs why don't you make a
movie about the suburbs now
where
people on tremblone kill their parents
because that's the suburbs now
people on trenbolone killing their
parents how about you make that hunky
dory
hey adam mckay how about you make that
movie
don't look up why
is there a meteor no my son's on
tremblone and he's got a gun
how about making that film
my roid rage son's trying to kill me and
my husband again
tim dilloncomedy.com for all uh live
dates we don't know uh what's going on
with the omicron and everything but
um
we'll we'll announce some more dates as
we have them
uh see everybody in san diego this
weekend or next weekend whatever
wednesday through sunday those
shows are sold out
uh uh tickets available for
i believe our third show that we've
added at the paramount in long island
um and camp ac theater in red bank new
jersey at the end of the month of
january everybody stays safe out there
everybody's getting uh infected
with
omicron uh toronto's move to february
25th toronto will now be on february
25th and that's as per toronto they shut
down one to half capacity for new year's
so
um yeah so uh for new year's
we will not be in toronto which sucks
but
what is fun is that we're going to be on
tremblog
tim j dillon d-i-l-l-o-n on instagram
and twitter and if you've not heard the
latest episode with joe rogan
we had such an amazing time i explained
um
the metaverse to joe and he explained
ivermectin to me
great episode everybody loves it and um
that's on spotify
also uh this is one of our final audio
only episodes we'll be back in the
studio
um our new studio
in january right
yes
that's right so we're very excited about
that
so this is one of our final audio only
episodes we know
you don't like the audio only episodes
and and we like to do some video
so
we have enough audio on the patreon
don't worry about it we will be back
in
the
new studio
which we're all very very excited about
now the awkward thing
about this new studio it was being
designed by dino thomasetti
so we got to get this guy out of jail
and we got to get him back to working on
the studio because i'll tell you one
thing about trenbolone it really makes
him motivated to work on the studio
so we're coming to get you dino
we love you dino
so
but the studio is on its way
right ben it's on its way we're not
expecting the first week in january but
the second monday in january will be
from that studio
and the first week we'll broadcast from
the studio that people know of you know
our our stu right our temporary our
temperament
well folks we've had a lot of fun
with you
i hope you enjoyed the holiday
our christmases were not really great
it's been very hard
um many people's christmases got [__]
up
by omicron or by delayed flights
cancelled flights
people are sitting in airports or
they're you know
to get into a a relative's house and
they're like they find out everybody's
sick
it's a nightmare
but there's certain places where
christmas
still happens no matter what
like
hewlett harbor
where no matter what
the true story of christmas
shines through all the [__]
anthony fauci can't stop what's coming
as they say in that your favorite movie
for a movie you like a lot
uh no country for old men
and that he thought she can't and you
know these were like you know this this
kid hated fouchy this guy
he's like fouchy's not gonna stop my
holiday plans
dino thomas said he's like hey fouchy's
not gonna stop me from doing what i have
to do
i hope they make a full recovery
i hope next year they're all sitting at
christmas dinner again
and i hope he says something and the
mother's like you shot us in the head
last year
and he's like you got to keep bringing
that up
you got to keep bringing that up
i can't [__] believe you
you gotta keep throwing that my face
that i shot you and dad
last year
i was having a bad day i was on
trenbolone
do you want to confess to lying about
covered before we we go
i want to know if this is a bit that you
think i'm lying about it
it's not a bit it's a it's a the reality
that we
are now new new things are coming to
light every day about the way you're
behaving
you said that your wife had covered
for like an hour
i believe she she still might have had
coveted right but i mean do you see
where we're at now with you with just
the constant like gray area that you
live in in terms of truth this isn't me
this is the times we're living in now oh
is it yeah cause things are just so
crazy
so it wasn't the nazis it was just the
times they were living in
because when you lie
and and say that you have covered
and you're like
i'm so sick here's the way it happens
okay okay ready okay
you're at home with your wife
and you go
now
you hear a call
and it's me right okay i'm gonna do what
you're doing up until the call
and then when you grab the call okay am
i calling you from san francisco like
you're on the road you're doing nothing
just sit there okay okay i'm calling you
okay
now
you're sitting there with your wife and
you're going uh you're going
um
yeah [__] that fat [__]
[Laughter]
we're gonna get all of his money and
then you're like oh speak of the devil
and then you're like hello
i'm sick
i can't even like
do anything like
my stomach hurts
i feel sick
maybe i should get more money
should i have more money
i know you've given me a lot of money
but
maybe i should have more of it
all right
thank you
for all your help i really
i really appreciate it click
that fat [__] thinks i'm sick
but i'm not i'm faking it and we're
gonna steal all of his money
that's kind of what happens
that's really the reality
you know it's the reality yep
what you want me to well i'm just trying
to connect a and b in my head right so
like how does me getting coveted mean
getting all of your money like in my
head like you you increase my sympathy
for you
you make me feel bad for you so i get
your guard down so that i can attack
you're you make me feel bad for you
mm-hmm
and that's what you do you build
sympathy
you're cooking it up
just like you call me go katie's sick
she said she's isolating and
we don't know what to do
you and her had something cooked up
you try to cook something else up but
then you decided that it's all house of
cards with you and her you and your wife
are
francis
and clara claire yes you are frank and
claire
yes francis
i'm kidding you're a janitor
and that and i i don't know that's not
negative to janitors it's negative to
you
um
timberlandcomedy.com
for all your tremblone
we're selling tremblog now
only if you kill your parents
first uh shipment of tremolone free if
you
videotape yourself killing your parents
and then tweet at me
don't do that
all right good night